[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
on va continuer à parler cette semaine
des conséquences de l'épidémie de kobe
mais pas seulement
et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission que j'ai deux bouchers bonjour
j'ai toujours ta main est notre invité
cette semaine est à la tête du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée c'est
le député de paris
gilles legendre bonjour j de légende
comme traduit bonjour aussi le boucher
aujourd'hui la jambe et c'est brigitte
qui va commencer par brosser votre
portrait gilles legendre vous êtes né le
13 mai 1958 à neuilly-sur-seine dans les
hauts-de-seine vous êtes président du
groupe la république en mach député de
paris mme acronis de la première heure
vous défendez coûte que coûte la
politique du gouvernement face aux
critiques vous ne concédait qu'une
erreur celle d'avoir probablement été
trop intelligente sur les mesures liées
au pouvoir d'achat c'était à l'époque
après le bac
ce sera sciences po il cfj votre coeur
balance entre deux spécialités parmi les
plus décriées par les français la
politique et le journalisme vous avez
occupé plusieurs postes de direction à
l'usiné nouvelle au nouvel économiste à
l'expansion l'événement du jeudi où
challenge avant d'arriver à l'assemblée
mais aujourd'hui vous êtes rattrapé par
vos premières amours puisque l'économie
française connaît une crise sans
précédent
une récession de 11% un déficit de 11,4
pour cent estimé à fin 2020 alors quel
oeil acéré aurait porté le journaliste
économique indépendant forcément sur
cette crise économique sans précédent
écoutez j'ai attendu d'avoir 62 ans pour
vivre probablement lé élevé d'événements
économiques le plus bouleversant qui est
connue la planète depuis la guerre est
donc en tant qu'observateur que je ne
suis plus probablement en or et j'étais
passionné et il n'y a qu'à lire les
journaux ou en regarder la télévision
entendre les radios pour voir à quel
point cette crise suscite des réflexions
des interrogations des interpellations
qui aurait été probablement été les
miennes si j'étais encore journaliste
que je ne suis plus quand même depuis
près de vingt ans donc le lot a coulé et
des maintiens aujourd'hui mais
maintenant mais majoritaires mais
maintenant nous sommes acteurs
et nous avons à relever tous ensemble un
défi phénoménal c'est à dire être
capable de répondre à cette crise avec
probablement des solutions totalement
inédites parce que cette crise là est
inédite et ce que je voudrais saluer
aujourd'hui c'est précisément l'option
que très tôt avant même que la pandémie
prennent tous sont sinistres élan le
gouvernement et notamment bruno le maire
ont tout de suite compris que nous
étions dans un schéma totalement inédit
et qu'il fallait faire éclater les
cadres habituels les règles habituelles
y compris vous l'avez dit les règles de
rigueur budgétaire qui ne s'appliquait
plus dans ce contexte là elles
reviendront et nous devrons être
rigoureux dans la manière dont nous
dépensons l'argent mais d'être capable
d'aller tout de suite chercher des
solutions inédites ce qui a été fait
avec le chômage partiel avec le fonds de
soutien avec le les prêts et garanties
par l'état etc etc
j'ai les jambes on va continuer à parler
et des conséquences du coc vite dans
cette émission avec d'abord une
commission d' enquête sur l'épidémie de
covin 19 elle va débuter ses travaux mi
juin sous la houlette du rapporteur les
républicains eric ciotti qui veut la
vérité sur la gestion des masques et de
10 1 10e groupe parlementaire s'est créé
à l'assemblée nationale deux groupes ont
vu le jour en deux semaines avec des
députés issus de la majorité mais pas
seulement la crise couve dans cette
majorité
enfin assouplir le régime des
procurations et améliorer la
participation lors du deuxième tour des
municipales fixées le 28 juin c'est
l'objectif d'une proposition de loi
adoptée cette semaine au sénat
la balle est désormais dans le camp de
la santé et on commence par le premier
thème de cette émission l'assemblée qui
va enquêter sur l'épidémie de
coronavirus
[Musique]
la mission d'information sur le co vite
19 lancers en mars dote des pouvoirs
d'enquêté pour six mois
vraies prérogatives d'une commission
denquête c'était une demande des
républicains évoqué pour septembre elle
débutera finalement ses travaux dès la
mi juin presque en même temps que celle
du sénat les précisions de stéphanie des
pierres c'est 30 députés vont enquêter
sur la gestion de l'épidémie de
coronavirus ils peuvent convoquer qui
ils veulent et les auditions se font
sous serment
l'opposition attend les premiers
témoignages avec impatience le député
l'est républicain eric ciotti a obtenu
le poste clef de rapporteur général
l'objectif c'est la vérité c'est faire
la vérité sur ce qui s'est passé sur ce
qui a fonctionné mais aussi sur ce qui a
dysfonctionné sur nos failles sur
certaines faillite le champ
d'investigation est très large masque
test gestion des ehpad confinement
déconfinement le patron des républicains
est l'un des quatre vice-présidents de
la commission denquête il promet que la
droite n'en fera pas un procès politique
l'objectif voilà c'est d'éviter c'est
d'éviter finalement qu'on fasse un
benalla bis l'objectif ce n'est pas d'en
faire un tribunal populaire de viser la
responsabilité judiciaire de tel ou tel
ministre
non notre objectif c'est la
responsabilité politique les
défaillances dysfonctionnements les
failles qui a eu dans le système à l'été
2010 8 la commission benalla avait
implosé après des divergences sur les
personnes à auditionner la majorité se
prépare donc à des moments difficiles
mais brigitte bourguignon la présidente
de la commission denquête affiche son
ouverture les propositions d'audition
c'est l'opposition surtout qui va les
proposer
et puis ensuite nous aussi on pourra en
proposer bien sûr et moi par principe je
m'opposerai à aucune des auditions parce
que personne n'a intérêt à s'opposer à
des auditions
quelle qu'elle soit les auditions
devraient commencer à mi juin ministres
hauts fonctionnaires médecins la liste
promet d'être longue
edouard philippe et agnès buzyn tous
deux candidats aux municipales ne seront
entendus qu'après le second tour
j'ai le gens nous avaient entendu damien
abad le président des républicains qui
sera vice président de cette commission
denquête je suis aussi nous sommes tous
les deux le voilà il ya quatre vice
présidents dont damien abad et votre
serviteur et votre serviteur vous vous
dites et on l'entend lui dire il n'y
aura pas tribunal populaire est ce que
vous craignez quand même une affaire
banale abyss pas du tout pas du tout
nous ne sommes pas du tout dans le même
schéma
nous sommes sur une analyse qui complexe
et qui justifie parfaitement cette
commission denquête nous ne nous sommes
pas fait imposer cette commission
denquête nous la souhaitons avec la même
intensité avec la même énergie que les
groupes d'opposition
elle est indispensable mais eric ciotti
qu'est nommé rapporteur général de la
commission denquête n'a vraiment pas été
le plus tendre avec vous je suis non
mais attendez
mais mais mais il n'y a pas une question
de tendresse ou pas de tendresse
erik satie dit quoi dans votre reportage
il dit nous voulons connaître la vérité
eh bien oui nous voulons nous aussi
connaît ça veut dire qu'une mission
d'information qui existait avant puisque
en fait cette commission enquête est
issu de la mission d'information n'a pas
permis c'est de faire tout dans leur
objet non brigitte boucher leur objet
est radicalement différent la mission
d'information était là pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement pendant la
gestion de la crise sanitaire sous tous
les aspects d'ailleurs pas que sanitaire
économique social et comprendre les
mesures du gouvernement
le confinement le de confinement le
rythme les mesures de protection les
mesures de prévention c'était ça son
objet est ce qu eric ciotti là le temps
la vérité commence on n'est plus dans le
temps la communication de gaitan dire ça
c'est de la communication et ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup non
la commission denquête elle doit
comprendre pourquoi et comment nous
avons géré cette crise la guerre est un
état d c'est important et pas simplement
sur ce qui a commencé au mois de mars
tout ce qui a précédé et qui fait que le
système sanitaire a bien répondu sur
certains aspects
- rennes à moins bien répondu sur
d'autres comprendre et surtout
l'objectif de tout ça c'est que nous en
tirions des enseignements utiles pour la
suite
vous savez moi je vais vous dire très
clairement nous sommes extrêmement
serein sur la manière dont les choses
ont été menées nous avions un objectif
très clair qui a été partagé avec les
français dès le début éviter la
saturation dans les hôpitaux
évitez souvenez-vous nous avions sous sa
en esprit que nous soyons obligés de
faire des tris entre les malades ça n'a
jamais eu lieu et si c'était ça et c'est
parce que ça a été bien gérée maintenant
est-ce que sur certains points président
de la république l'avait dit le 13 avril
ya pu y avoir des défaillances ya pu
avoir des insuffisances dans la gestion
quand nous ne découvrons pas faire cette
journée masques et aussi des trois du
actif quand nous avons découvert que
l'essentiel des produits actifs des
produits de raimu de réanimation étaient
produits par des pays étrangers
ça c'est des choses qui sont
inacceptables mais c'est pas la
responsabilité de notre gouvernement est
une chaîne tout une histoire
oui sur la gestion des masques
n'auriez-vous pas mieux fait d'admettre
dès le début de la crise qu'il y avait
une pénurie de masques
incité par exemple les français à
fabriquer les leurs poteaux de dire à
l'époque on se rappelle tout de même ses
membres de dire que les masques ne
servait à rien que les français ne
seraient pas les mettre est ce que vous
voulez mais tu es aujourd'hui que c'est
vraiment je pense que c'était une erreur
de dire ça mais c'était pas une erreur
qui a été fait au hasard
au même moment l'organisation mondiale
de la santé disait la même chose vous
savez ce qui caractérise et ça c'est un
des résultats de la mission
d'information c'était pas pour cacher la
bio mairie non non non non non tu une
erreur vous leur comité
c'est une erreur c'est une espèce
defacto puisque c'était un point d'accès
un point de fixation qui a été un
élément perturbateur de tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire de très bien par ailleurs
mais vous savez c'est ce que c'est une
des choses qui est apparu de façon très
claire pendant la mission d'information
lors qu'on a eu 17 audition donc on a
fait du travail sérieux c'est de voir
comment sur cette crise
les vérités se sont apparus de manière
successive parfois contradictoires dans
le temps et parfois contradictoires à un
même moment entre différentes sources
les autorités scientifiques n'étaient
pas d'accord sur tout à tout moment et
ce aujourd'hui ça ça reconnaissait qu on
veut que les stocks de masques et être
suffisant il était à l'évidence mais il
était à l'évidence pour des situations
sanitaires que toute façon il était
extrêmement difficile de prévoir et
d'anticiper
je pense que là dessus on ne nous y
reprendra pas mais quand je dis nous
c'est pas le gouvernement
c'est le pays c'est la france c'est son
organisation il ya une responsabilité
des exécutifs antérieures pour vous
justement la gauche les communistes 10
la raison pour laquelle vous avez
accepté cette commission d' enquête de
la part de la droite et pas celle que
voulait les communistes et parce que
vous êtes lié c'est parce que eh bien
tout vous avez tous eu les mêmes
responsabilités vous avez tous été celle
exercée trop facile la proposition de la
commission du groupe gdr a été refusée
tout simplement parce qu'elle est
apparue av
après que nous avions décidé de
transformer la mission d'information en
commission denquête nous l'avions dit
dès le début c'est pas une mesure
opportuniste la commission denquête dès
le début le président richard ferrand
avait dit première phase mission
d'information pour exercer les pressions
des républiques non exercés non nous
étions très déterminé nous l'avions même
mis dans la loi pour que douchez nous
avions même dit que il y avait dans la
loi d'urgence la première celle du 23
mars
l'obligation que le gouvernement
viennent périodiquement rendre des
comptes à la représentation nationale
sur la manière dont était géré la crise
c'était le rôle de cette mission et
agnès buzyn qui a parlé hors commission
denquête puisqu'elle n'était pas
constituée elle a parlé dans le monde
elle a parlé de mascarade à propos des
municipales elle a dit qu'elle avait
alerté très tôt le couple exécutif est
ce que vous craignez qu'à l'issue de
cette commission denquête il ya des
têtes qui doivent tomber mais non ce
n'est pas un tribunal une commission
denquête une commission d'enquêté
portant sabilité dans une parlementaire
a des pouvoirs très puissant et c'est
d'ailleurs très utile et investissent
hier non non non non non non mais y
avoir de poursuites judiciaires ou
initier des commissions locales et la
coupe le parlement n'a pas pourquoi je
dis ça mais en revanche il a des
pouvoirs de contrainte de ceux de
convoquer on ne peut pas s'y soustraire
honte honte on témoigne sous serment
donc c'est très solennelle est très fier
et c'est très bien comme ça moi je
défends cette initiative de la défense
sans réserve mais je n'ai aucune crainte
sur le fait que la vérité qui apparaîtra
sera une vérité utile et pas une vérité
polémique allégé légende on poursuit
cette émission avec la cre
a sion d'un dixième groupe à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
deux groupes parlementaires ont vu le
jour en deux semaines à l'assemblée avec
des députés issus en partie de la
république en marche avec dix groupes le
record est battu sous la vème république
hégémonique au début du quinquennat le
groupe majoritaire connaît une lente
érosion les explications de stéphanie
des pierres sur un pont de paris juste
devant l'assemblée se joue une drôle de
scène voici 17 députés a à peine des
confiné il vient d'annoncer la création
d'un nouveau groupe au palais bourbon
tous ou presque étaient des élus en
marche
les voici en dissidence le groupe
s'appelle écologie démocratie solidarité
c'est le neuvième groupe à l'assemblée
un record sous la vème république
une semaine plus tard
quelques mètres plus loin l'histoire se
répète voici encore 17 députés
mais ce ne sont pas les mêmes on prend
ses distances et on pose pour la photo
voici le dixième groupe qui vient de
naître
il s'appelle agir ensemble deux nouveaux
groupes en une semaine
le premier se veut une alternative plus
à gauche plus écologiste que la
république en marche
on est vraiment à un tournant après
cette crise sanitaire où il ya des
décisions qui vont être prises qui vont
être structurantes pour l'avenir de la
france pour l'avenir de la planète
donc nous on veut peser sur ses
décisions pour que la sortie de crise
soient marquées par une justice sociale
et par une justice environnementale
l'autre groupe agir ensemble est au
centre-droit proche d'edouard philippe
il comprend aussi sept députés de la
république en marche
nous pensons que face à la vague qui est
en train de déferler qui dit il faut
démondialiser déconstruire l'europe
revenir à l'état providence des années
80 nous pensons que c'est tout le
contraire
il faut revoir la mondialisation la
rendre plus humaine plus juste mais nous
avons besoin de la mondialisation
ce dixième groupe s'inscrit clairement
dans la majorité pour le 9e c'est ni
majorité ni opposition mais à eux deux
ces nouveaux groupes ont débauché 14
députés marcheurs
ils font donc perdre la majorité absolue
ou groupe la république en marche pas
vraiment une surprise plutôt le résultat
d'une lente érosion en 2017 il y avait
300 14 marcheurs à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que 280
gilles legendre deux groupes ont vu le
jour en moins de deux semaines ici à
l'assemblée nationale il ya désormais
dix groupes
à quand le 11e à écouter ça n'est pas
avant qu'il créerait c'est ça la
question
je porte est ouverte il y en avoir
d'autres écoutez par définition on vient
d'en avoir l'exemple la création des
groupes est libre ça n'est pas
souhaitable
ça n'est pas souhaitable c'est un
facteur de confusion dix groupes à
l'assemblée nationale ça ne s'est jamais
vu et c'est probablement quelque chose
qui va compliquer le fonctionnement
l'assemblée nationale l'assemblée
nationale est capable d'accueillir et
d'absorber mais ça ne va pas faciliter
ni clarifier le travail parlementaire
après on va faire avec président du
groupe de la république en marche c'est
un échec personnel que ses divisions
dans c'est une déception c'est un regret
mais ça n'est pas un échec personnel ou
jeunes est fragilisé pas du tout je ne
porte en rien seule la responsabilité de
tout le fonctionnement d'une majorité
d'une relation entre un petit crucifix
quelque chose à un moment ce groupe mais
je me le dis tous les jours brigitte
boucher tous les jours je me dis que
nous pourrions faire mieux
nous pourrions faire mieux et je
pourrais faire mieux
écoutez on ne retient pas les gens
contre leur gré il n'y a pas d' acte
d'autorité dans un groupe parlementaire
tout ça est le résultat d'un moment très
évident qu est cette crise si
particulière dont nous disions un mot au
tout début qui évidemment probablement
agite un certain nombre d'esprits créer
un certain nombre d' aspiration ou
libère un certain nombre de d'énergie
qui était déjà en jeu et qui se sont
exprimés dans la création c'est sans
trop de monde quand même et à plus loin
en tout cas une aile du groupe les
maisons de jeu notamment qui s'est
sentie inaudible qui est parti du 1er
mai moi d'abord je n'ai jamais raisonné
en termes d le gaucher des le droite au
sein du groupe est ce que je constate
c'est que plusieurs choses premièrement
tout ça ne déstabilise en rien la
majorité nous avons 344 députés de la
majorité
donc 281 en marche sur 577 députés
donc non seulement la majorité est
solide dans je vous signale à l'une et à
l'autre que jamais jamais une voix n'a
manqué au gouvernement depuis trois ans
sur quelques textes que ce soit et c'est
ça ma mission je peux regretter plein de
choses je peux dire qu'on aurait fait
plein de choses formidables
mais le boulot il a été fait là dessus
par ailleurs nous restons le groupe en
marche
l'épiné dorsale de cette majorité est
fort de 180 sur 342,71 davantage avec
eux en avant mais je puis joué depuis le
premier jour mais non mais ni plus ni
moins depuis le premier jour je ne sais
pas je compose
mais je travaille avec le modem nous
nous voyons toutes les semaines avec
patrick mignola et avec nos équipes
respectives et nous voyons sur quel vote
sur quel sujet comment nous allons voter
comme ils s'y retrouvent pas aurélien
tâche et a dit si je veux rester de
gauche doit quitter le lars helland cas
en ce sont des démarches personnelles
vous oblige à tenir les promesses de
2017 je pense à la bioéthique je pense à
la réforme des retraites
à toutes ces réformes les leçons de la
réforme bioéthique nous la voterons et
le plus tôt sera le mieux nous
l'adopterons définitivement avant la fin
du quinquennat mais pas seulement avant
la fin des quinas beaucoup plus vite que
la fin du quinquennat
j'ai dit l hôtel proche de vos confrères
d'une autre chaîne de télévision que ce
serait très difficile avant l'été si
c'est possible pourquoi pas mais j'ai du
mal à l'imaginer mais très vite après
l'été il faut que cette loi soit adoptée
les retraites c'est différent les
circonstances ont changé et notamment la
question du financement des retraites la
question du travail prendre évidemment
une autre couleur à l'aune de la crise
que nous vivons est donc il faudra
probablement l'adapter nous avons eu la
semaine prochaine et la semaine suivante
à discuter d'une proposition de loi sur
les retraites agricoles
c'est à dire manière de rentrer dans le
sujet nous allons voir de quelle manière
nous le ferons donc là il faudra
probablement adapter les choses
mais vous savez d'abord ces deux groupes
n'ont rien à voir il ya un groupe qui
est sorti de la majorité est un groupe
qui
d'y rentrer de façon très claire c'est
le groupe je vous l'avais dit sacré
quand même de la confusion
abel la multiplicité des groupes dans le
dans le fonctionnement de l'assemblée
nationale puisque vous en êtes l'une et
l'autre familière c'est incontestable
mais ensuite on vivra avec et sur la
majorité maintenant elle a 3 pac-3
mouvement trois groupes d'importance
très différente 17 membres pour agir
ensemble 46 membres pour le modem 2 181
membres pour la république en mars allez
on avance et on va parler d'une
proposition de loi de la droite
sénatoriale pour faciliter le vote lors
du second tour des élections municipales
[Musique]
le sénat a adopté un texte pour
favoriser procuration et vote par
correspondance
mardi la chambre haute a débattu ce
texte issu des républicains objectif
améliorer la participation lors du
second tour des municipales fixées les
28 juin le gouvernement est contre fait
de l'arrêt caire sur le déroulement du
second tour des municipales sénat et
gouvernement ne sont que partiellement
d'accord objectif de la proposition de
loi de la droite et du centre contre l
abstention record du premier tour
notamment facilitant le vote par
procuration il nous paraît tout à fait
essentiel que des mesures soient prises
pour rassurer et nous comptions le faire
en parfaite harmonie avec le
gouvernement et la majorité
parlementaire
car il s'agit d'un impératif d'intérêt
supérieur pour le bon fonctionnement de
la démocratie
le sénat a donc adopté le texte mais
contre l'avis du gouvernement qui entend
portant reprendre à son compte certaines
propositions des sénateurs votre
proposition de loi comprend des mesures
utiles et le gouvernement les partage
mais encore une fois pardon d'insister
de souligner le fait qu'elle ne relève
pas du domaine de la loi
aussi sont elles susceptibles d'être
mises en oeuvre et je leur dis comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure par décret
vouera même par simple circulaire le
texte des sénateurs proposent de porter
d'une à deux le nombre de procurations
pour un mandataire et veut assouplir les
règles de la procuration à domicile en
direction des personnes fragiles
le sénat veut aussi permettre à une
personne de donner procuration un
mandataire même s'il n'est pas inscrit
sur la même liste électorale à condition
qu'il s'agisse d'un proche
le gouvernement est contre contre aussi
le rétablissement du vote par
correspondance
un des points majeurs de cette
proposition de loi qui la sortie de
garanties pour prévenir la fraude
il nous semble que la faisabilité
juridique et technique de la mise en
place du vote par correspondance à ce
stade paraît très délicate à mettre en
oeuvre ou de proposer le vote par
correspondance aux calendes grecques
c'est à dire c'est qu'à landes qui
n'existe pas le gouvernement qui
présente son propre projet de loi au
parlement
débattue le 5 juin à l'assemblée
nationale le texte prévoit la
possibilité d'annuler le second tour en
cas de reprise de l'épidémie projet de
loi qui devrait également
été plusieurs dispositions relatives au
déroulement de ce second tour
gilles l'agente sur le fond ne faut-il
pas faciliter le vote par procuration le
vote par correspondance dès le prochain
scrutin de façon urgente pour avoir un
minimum de participation mais ça n'est
pas raisonnable ça n'est pas résolu ça
n'est techniquement pas réaliste même
réglementaires rappelle que le vote par
correspondance a été supprimée en 1975
parce que il fonctionnait fort mal et
qui ne garantissait pas une sincérité en
ligne un système 15
oui ça veut dire que le vote par
correspondance n'est pas la panacée et
que ça se travaille et que les élections
municipales du second tour étant dans
trois semaines
il n'est pas raisonnable de vouloir le
faire dès maintenant est-ce qu'il va pas
y avoir un problème de sincérité du
scrutin le 28 juin c'est ce que
plusieurs élans neurologue et senna
matri y en aurait atteint il y en aurait
tu as si nous bouclions le vote par
correspondance et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement et partisans
d'être prudent mais vous savez il en
sera de ce domaine comme dans beaucoup
d'autres nous aurons des leçons à tirer
de cette crise et notamment probablement
faire évoluer les pratiques électorales
mais le faire à froid sérieusement en
serre ayant tous les aspects de la
question il ya quelque chose qu'on peut
faire rapidement
si en vente l'autorisation de deux
procurations par personne aujourd'hui il
sera président rouleau le 28 juin je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait envisageable est souhaitable
on va réglementer mais mais mais est
d'ailleurs dans le dans la même ville
dans la même commune ne faisons pas
sauter parce que là pour le coup il ya
des problèmes de vérification qui dans
l'urgence risquerait d'être mal
organisés et malgré un mois des
municipales des accords ont été conclus
entre les républicains et la république
en marche avec des mouvements politiques
à clermont c'est notre combat politique
publique boucher beaucoup entre les
récents matchs est ce que ça veut dire
que la république en marche pour chats
droite certainement pas certainement pas
et je le dis et c'est d'ailleurs non
sans rapport avec ce que nous nous
sommes dit sur les aigles et les groupes
et la création des nouveaux groupes
le mouvement la république en marche
sous l'impulsion de stanislas guérini
sous l'impulsion forte courageuse et
utile de stanislas guérini et le groupe
reste les lieux du dépassement politique
du dépassement du clivage droite gauche
non pas pour nier l'existence des
sensibilités les uns et les autres nous
sommes le produit d'une histoire
politique de convictions politiques que
nous n'avons jamais abdiqué mais nous
reconnaissons depuis 2010 est que ce
clivage a plutôt était plutôt été un
facteur de conservatisme de frein dans
l'évolution dans les progrès du pays
qu'il importe de dépasser et ce qui
était vrai en 2017 l'être encore plus
aujourd'hui ou pour trouver les bonnes
réponses à la crise économique à la
crise sociale
nous devons être très imaginatif et nous
débarrasser des oripeaux des vieilles
solutions des vieilles des vieilles
méthodes des solutions toutes faites
comme je les voit réapparaître et sur
notre flanc droit et sur notre flanc
gauche donc plus que jamais nous devons
nous départ il ne reste une minute on va
terminer avec le rapport sévère rendu
par la commission d' enquête sénatoriale
sur la gestion de l'incendié de lubrizol
les sénateurs dénoncent des angles morts
inacceptables dans la prévention des
risques industriels en france
il pointe la responsabilité de l'état il
critique la communication de l'exécutif
et critique notamment agnès buzyn est ce
que ça ne fait pas un nouveau caillou
dans la chaussure dans cette campagne
agnès buzyn à les critiquer avec tout ce
qu'elle a pu dire pendant la campagne de
paris et puis maintenant encore ça non
mais attendez
quel est l'élément central de ce rapport
et que je le trouve fondée si les
difficultés de communication qui ont eu
lieu mais qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qui est important dans une crise comme
ça c'est la gestion réelle de la crise
sur lequel porte aucun reproche
c'est à dire notamment en termes de
réactivité de rapidité des réponses à
apporter
ou est ce que c'est la communication
vous savez quand une crise surgit comme
ça vous n'avez pas immédiatement le bon
ton le bon discours cela aussi ce qui
est important c'est les leçons qu'on en
tire et le ministre elisabeth borne à
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire a déjà lancé la concertation
qui va permettre de tirer les leçons
elle a déjà décidé d'augmenter de 50%
les contrôles des sites classés donc de
tous ces événements
nous essaierons de la fin merci gilles
legendre ont vu leur prix merci tu as
merci j'ai bien évidemment la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro et
d'eau
[Musique]